según el gangs violence artibe ya van
más de 160 tiroteos masivos tan solo en
lo que va del año 2023 en Estados Unidos
qué hay detrás según ustedes de esta
tendencia violenta en el país
mira en Santiago yo creo que esta
tendencia lo que refleja es todavía una
pasividad del gobierno y que la
población lo siente y es este este hecho
de que suban estas estas estas estos
hechos lo que nos hace ver es todavía el
tema de que el portación y tenencia no
ha sido abordado y la gente todavía eh
No sé estaba en un momento en el que te
están
incrementando esos hechos y va a hacer
que los políticos por fin empiecen a
preocuparse al respecto de eso Entonces
en medio de esto está la aportación y la
tenencia que sigue teniendo la misma
Libertad en este momento Hacia dónde
debe avanzar esa legislación respecto
del porte de armas
yo creo que debe avanzar en dos días
importantes Santiago uno en limitar la
edad ya no de 18 no a veintiún años y
dos el hecho de que las personas que
puedan acceder a esa tenencia y
portación sean a partir de de exámenes
porque Cuál ha sido el problema de estos
últimos hechos son personas que tienen
ciertos problemas mentales Por decirlo
así entonces debe haber esa limitación
también de que estas personas no tengan
un acceso con tanta libertad hablemos
ahora un poco de las víctimas hay una
encuesta de la ong family foundation que
revela que el 19% de los ciudadanos de
Estados Unidos tiene algún familiar que
murió por uso de arma de fuego no vamos
a hablar particularmente de las personas
afroamericanas que son las más afectadas
dentro de esta población el 34% de ellas
tiene un familiar que murió por un arma
es común que haya un componente racial
en muchos de estos ataques armados
Fíjate que no es así tanto que sea un
componente racial como hay otro hecho
otro porcentaje que te voy a dar del
100% de ataques donde los afroamericanos
han sido involucrados el 96% ha sido por
otro afroamericano o sea es el 96% de de
entre afroamericanos que tiene estos
estos ataques Por decirlo así entonces
yo no veo un tema racial sino que veo la
misma posibilidad de acceso a las armas
y que en estos casos ha sido un bolsones
de las ciudades que siempre han
manifestado una tendencia a la violencia
por último quisiera preguntarle si hay
un clima particular en estos momentos
que lleve a este tipo de hechos está
atravesando a Estados Unidos un clima
más violento que en otros años
yo no creo que sea un clima más violento
que otros años sino que es más
manifiesto me explico la tendencia y el
porcentaje de estos ataques de la
aportación si tú quieres se ha mantenido
en los últimos cuatro años pero es más
manifiesto por la cantidad digamos por
la intensidad llamémoslo de esa manera
la intensidad y el alcance que está
teniendo es la diferencia en relación a
los años anteriores